سالنا الناس هل يجب ان يرتبط عدد الابناء
بمستوى الدخل ونرجع لكم سيد اسماء دكتور
البلد محدود الدخل يعني يجيب اولاد كثير
ما هو مشكله في المعيشه لانه الدوله ما
بترعى يعني التعليم ما يكون مضبوط ولا ولا
الصحه مضبوط ويعني يعني الولد راح يتغلب
في ال في البلد اللي معيشته تكون ضعيفه
هذه رزقه الاطفال رزقه يعني انا مثلا مثال
يعني ما بخلف ما عندي اطفال بالمره ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى اراد لان انا اكون من غير
اطفال بس انما لو اراد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
يرزقني نشرحها قصر يعني واحد اثنين ثلاثه
هو عطاء رباني وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
بيرزقنا وبيرزقهم يعني زياده عن مصدر دخلك
صح هو الارزاق بايد ربنا اكيد بس برده
الواحد لازم
حياه كريم
فلوس
التربيه والتعليم
والصحه